[Music]
to get started with the cloud natural
language API for Python
you need a GCP project which you can
setup in the console
in your project enable the google
natural language API for that project
then create a service account and
download the private key as Jason you
use these credentials to access google
cloud api's so keep it secure and out of
your code and public repos
to access the credentials from your
project set up an environment variable
I'm going to use PyCharm as my IDE so
the way I set up a variable is different
I'll show you that shortly if you aren't
using pycharm go to the terminal and set
an environment variable to the path of
your service account prepare your
environment for Python development again
I'm using PyCharm but you can use
whatever dev environment you prefer if
you are using PyCharm then under run
select edit configurations in the
section environment there's an
environment variable field click on this
and add the Google application
credentials here next install the client
library from the terminal or IDE if you
use cloud shell in the console you can
skip this set since the required
dependencies are already included make a
new file or open an existing file import
the Google cloud client library and then
instantiate a client
provide some text to analyze I'm going
to go with a classic example here now
create a document which has a field
called content set to the text you are
analyzing and a field called type which
as the name suggests is the type of text
in this case plain text call analyze
sentiment passing the document this
function returns an analyze sentiment
response analyze sentiment response has
three properties document sentiment the
overall sentiment of the input document
language the language of the text and
sentences the sentiment for all the
sentences in the document set the
sentiment variable to the document
sentiment log the parameters of
sentiment score and magnitude scores a
sentiment score between negative 1 for
negative sentiment and positive 1 for
positive sentiment magnitude is a number
between 0 and infinity which represents
the absolute magnitude of the sentiment
regardless of positive or negative score
ok go ahead and run the code there you
go you've just sent your first request
to the natural language API but there's
so much more that the cloud natural
language API can do like analyzing
syntax and annotating text to find out
more about the client libraries consult
natural language basics or work through
the sentiment analysis tutorial check
out the cloud documentation
you